i do apologize for my hair
i'm getting some comments about it it
has not been cut in quite a while
um and now it's really just doing its
own thing it's all over the place
uh it is starting to absorb the energy
around it the anger the frustration the
fear
that people have about kovid it's
absorbing that anxiety
and becoming a freakish freakish
mess kind of a weather vein for these
strange times we're in
but i'll get it under control i do
promise and uh
i'm not just here to babble about my
hair i may be self-centered but i'm not
that self-centered i wanted to talk
about an issue here at the top of the
show
that affects everyone i'm talking about
masks
the pandemic as we know still out of
control in the united states
for months now health officials have
been saying we can drastically reduce
covet outbreaks simply by wearing a face
mask
here's the problem many people are still
going out in public without one
that got me thinking what if they made a
mask that people
actually wanted to wear think about it
something fun something fashionable even
sexy well our newest sponsor thinks
they may have that mask take a look
summer's here and the heat is hot you
need a face mask that's barely there
you need the maschini
two skimpy strips of fabric that cover
your mouth and nose
exposing more cheek more chin and more
upper lip than
any other face mask on the market you'll
be turning heads
raising eyebrows and more
get the mask the centers for disease
control calls
100 sexy
and they're not just for women they kind
of are
they are yeah
wherever fake products are sold